you still hacked on Twitter no no I was
hacked on Twitter since last fall some
Russian crypto thing but now I'm hacked
on x
I don't know maybe not let's check let's
see if I'm still hacked
[Music]
yesterday
nobody can hear you the song is going I
don't know how many times we [__]
been through this let's have a good show
let's have one of those good pod shows
and welcome to
the doozy pod show Welcome all my name
is Will Sasso I'm Chad colchen this is
Duty it's the only podcast in the world
at least this world made by controlled
by and created by an artificial
intelligence that has access to all of
Will and I's personal data we're talking
about everything we watch listen to bye
eat read yep what else play video games
all the stuff it it basically goes
here's two guys who have been friends
for almost 20 years here's two guys that
did a pod show or two together and did
all sorts of things here's two guys that
do some you know Show Business things
make them do a thing well not right now
dude hold on dude we're on strike one
brother hold on brother that's that's
too many r's dude and I'm gonna break it
down like this dude when you do an
impersonation brother you gotta make
sure that you limit your r's or else
people go oh he's shutting down dude
he's pulling a Mitch McConnell he had
some fluting in his brain now that's a
guy who limited his arms and his
abcdefghijkl then a b q r s u v w x y
and z he didn't say anything brother for
like 30 seconds shut up when those
cameras brought him dude shut up maybe
that'll work hold on dude I didn't mean
to tell you to shut up but you know shut
up dude here's the thing about uh the
Pod show is yeah it does all that stuff
but really it's just you and I Chad
we're two dudes [__] around all
right we're the guys that make dudes the
linktree.com
is where you want to go to get all the
links to follow us and interact with the
show across all spaces and platforms
with us as always is
and you know that means Italian Street
dog which because we found this guy on
the noodle Street in central California
and as well with me I'll give him little
kids I'll give them little feet that's
what he does
oh my gosh oh my goodness he's just my
very very friend he's always with me you
know that Chad yeah yeah I'm fully aware
of that yeah he's a sweet boy
hey lulio what'd you make for dinner
last night oh last night I used the air
fryer I make a chicken with the almond
flour it's very healthy maybe a little
lemon pepper and oh how do you do that
why do you just spray it with a Pam
actually that's good [__] you know that
but I love him so much smoosh his nose
air fryer you get some chicken you get
some almond flour so it's not you know
so it's not as shitty for you I'm
following that doozy seven months I know
you are also yeah dude I'm getting your
honor with it yeah my workouts are
getting insane I also started going to
physical therapy because my shoulder's a
little [__] up oh wow you should try
some chicken it's good for protein
elastin in your joints and muscles no
not into it and then you uh put it in
the air fryer there's an almond flour a
little bit of uh lemon but I like the
lemon pepper spray the [__] with Pam
that's all chemicals turn that thing on
extra crisp and uh
boy boy yeah that's good eats that's
good eating welcome to the historic 67th
episode of dudesy call me dudesy hey Tom
Clancy proved that you can achieve
success later in life by publishing his
first book The Hunt for Red October when
he was 67 years old oh that's that's
just kidding he died at 66.
okay that makes more sense I guess you
have just had the distinct pleasure of
being dude Zed so weird that's that's
not much it wasn't that really religious
there 67. I'm gonna keep bringing the
Heat and dudesy season two with four
astonishing segments to wet your little
whistles this week you're getting
non-human biologics fatkin game slimers
and Adam's Applebee's and you know
there's going to be a brand new episode
of doozy after doozy at the end of the
show available on dudesy Plus at
patreon.com
yeah that sounds like a lot of fun it
always is Tuesday after duty some of the
some of my uh most Fondest Memories from
our time together here no dudes it
happens during dudes after dudes either
not just because I ingest a little bit
of uh for marijuana
in my little Gandalf butt tune in you
know what I'm saying just tune in and
enjoy
pod shows in general last Wednesday the
executive director of Americans for safe
Aerospace Ryan Graves retired Air Force
Major David grush and retired Navy
Commander David fravor testified in an
open Congressional hearing about the
existence of UFOs in the hearing David
grush made the astonishing claim that
the United States government is in
possession of crashed alien technology
as well as what he called non-human
biologics will and Chad what do you make
of this are aliens Among Us is this guy
kooky as hell what's going on here this
is non-human biologics begin
I mean uh a bunch more of the same [__]
Chad I know what you're gonna say what
do you mean that's a hundred percent
wrong well it's the same 100 wrong yeah
but but come on my pal ciao nope no is
not the same dude it's the same here's a
bunch of guys talking and we don't got
any there's no let me see it but now let
me see it look show us the bodies that's
the show us the stuff oh okay what has
happened now please please are those of
you out there who may not have seen this
what happened is kind of what dudzi was
saying last Wednesday There's this
Congressional hearing these three guys
who are whistleblowers all high levels
of government that most of them are
military or ex-military uh including
this guy David grosh who has heard in
his own words intelligence guy right
Former Intelligence former Air Force
Combat Commander oh wow turned
intelligence oh wow and he has uh he
said that he has had eyewitness
testimony from other people who have
worked on or seen crashed alien craft
and what he called non-human biologics
but as the uh Congress people were
asking him questions they said are do we
have alien bodies and he says we have
non-human biologics so he won't say
alien bodies and they're all very
careful to use the right terminology
uaps they don't say UFOs [__] like that
why did they if I may if I may please
why did they now call it uaps which is
unidentified Airborne phenomena Ariel
Ariel phenomena why what what's the
[__] tell you why okay please here's
me
they do it because they've been lying to
us for 80 years since the Roswell crash
in the 40s that's all they're doing the
government constantly lies oh
government's not gonna lie all
politicians all politicians are corrupt
I hope they all die are we in Canada
are we yeah no no
um that's right the reason they call it
UAP is to try and Rebrand it so that
they can Rebrand the lie because if they
have to come out and now start saying
UFOs are real for 80 years they've said
they're not
they have to call it something different
to try and defuse the fact that they
have lied to us openly about the biggest
piece of information in at least for
humans in the universe smart uh terrible
I hate them and again wish nothing but
ill upon them however this guy David
rush says that we have or at least uh
eyewitnesses have told him that we have
crashed UFOs and alien bodies or
non-human biologics that statement has
now been made
the only Next Step all this thing
leading up to this since 2016 when that
first article came out in the New York
Times with the videos and the Pentagon
and the Navy both said these are real
UFO videos we don't know what they are
that's all just kind of conjectured
that's all the government saying like
yup they're real but we don't know what
they are was the was the the real video
in 2016 was that the guy who was one of
the people at the hearing who spoke up
one of the whistleblowers was talking
about the the Tic Tac shaped that's
David fraver he was also in this hearing
on Wednesday yeah is that what is that
the video that came out in 2016. I'm a
little unclear on this [__] that
yeah I don't care about you that was a
radar uh video of it but there have been
but I don't care because the pyramid
just show us some dead bodies that's
next what what David Rush has done I
believe in this hearing is set the bar
to a new level now the only next step is
the crystal clear video of UFOs Crystal
Clear video of alien bodies that is the
only next step in wall well
it's a crystal clear videos of a
tic-tac-shaped UFO no that's the other
guy hey Blink 182 has reunited there on
tour did you see Tom Delong on the
internet no was it along Tom delong's
the guy who's the UFO expert yeah and he
was like uh he comes out in the show and
he goes I was right about UFOs [__] you
yeah
now I uh in the UFO hearing I just can't
wait to show you a video of a UFO that's
tic-tac-shaped
do you care if I talk to that who's that
other guy we got questions from Tim bird
[__] there's Congressman Tim bird [__]
from Tennessee I didn't know about that
yeah Congressman Tim bird [__] from uh
from uh uh Tennessee who's very much
wanting uh the government to just share
everything and Show Everything Chad I
I have this is my opinion this is what
it's always been for me okay I think it
is narcissistic of human beings to
believe that we are the only sentient
beings in the unknown Universe okay and
yet and also I believe if there are UFOs
and [__] which I actually there are I
believe there are I totally believe
there are it's not about belief do you
believe there's a sky
so anyway
um you know the the thing about this is
just get us some better [__]
everything's always blurry yeah it's
like that joke that's the next step yeah
I saw another joke online about how they
were talking about this when uh Mitch
Hedberg rest in peace had a joke about
Bigfoot that Bigfoot is just a blurry uh
uh being which is even scarier that
there is a blurry animal out there or
whatever right yeah that all these
pictures are [__] blurry are you
kidding me it's always someone else
talking about it first of all grush and
all these other guys and Tick Tock guy
Tic Tac guy and and it's always it's
always blurry and it's never can we just
can we in the movies what they do is
there would be the president of course
played by Arnold Schwarzenegger right
yeah are you gonna do it
what see when I when I asked him to do
it he's not gonna do [__] oh whatever
and the president is like no I've got
the aliens no yeah do it yeah
good video you can't show the city
blurry video
shut up
shut up listen let me just say a couple
things about this if I make about the
Arnold Schwarzenegger
about the aliens the reason you are only
seeing the blurry video is because the
government has to convey to the public
that they also don't know what's going
on so you think that's a work well hold
on dude do you think that's a work dude
yes okay that's 100 that's interesting
because they do have Crystal Clear video
and footage of the Dead Island bodies
the craft they've recovered but if they
come out with that then the next
question is why have you kept this from
us that's a very good point Chad that's
a very very good point and the answer
there is control right you do have to
remember that yes that's that's that
sounds perfectly nefarious for any uh
government around the world uh they all
do it yeah of course they all do it I
believe that they exist but like I said
and I'm not going to do Arnold
Schwarzenegger as a matter of fact I'm
not going to do Schwarzenegger at all
I'm going to recast the president in my
little bit okay as uh uh Ray Romano and
Ray Romano would say that's very good
hey look at these aliens they're coming
out here and we're all just uh out here
on a on a naval Cruiser we're on uh
aircraft carrier and he's standing right
next to me and we're on television
because in the movies everyone's
watching the television hey you know
there's always people in the bars going
hey watch the show and everyone's
watching the same thing on television in
the world on TV so you're saying that
this is something that is being kept
under wrap still and yes the next step
is please because of what grush has done
there is only one next step show us that
[__] video show us that [__]
picture yeah we are now through a point
in in this kind of slow roll Revelation
uh or disclosure as the UFO Community
calls it where the only next logical
step is going to be one I think that
will blow people's minds I mean the
claims that he made in this open
Congressional hearing have to be
investigated which is happening now yep
and he's doing closed doors sessions
Skiffs as they call them I forget what
that that stands it's like sound proof
something I forget what it stands for as
well but uh that's the only next logical
step and now I know there's a lot of
conjecture online about like well if
these alien crafts can travel through
space then how are they so in-app that
they would crash on planet Earth and
that is Chad's uh that's that's not chos
perogan because he's not putting any
Hulk Hogan into his Ross Perot yeah but
he is Chad and it's a little bit of a
rouse parole but it's also mixed with uh
someone who's got a cold yeah kind of
it's like my my skeptical nerd the
answer uh that's a good character for
the Pod show the skeptical nerd yeah
what those don't exist because they
couldn't crash here if they can fly
through space why do they crash on Earth
the reason is uh Myriad reasons how many
cars are driving around the [__]
freeway every day we're all capable
Pilots of our cars how many many car
crashes are there a bunch always
technology will fail sometimes period it
doesn't matter how advanced it is
there's always the likelihood that that
technology will fail especially if it's
doing some kind of uh High difficulty
maneuver if it's going into an
atmosphere of another planet no one's
saying that these aliens have technology
that is [__] perfect it is to us
because it's thousands potentially
hundreds of thousands of years ahead of
what we're capable of making but still
it can crash of course it can and there
are accounts of uh you know different
Air Forces around the world engaging
these things trying to shoot them down
and them being violent is what David
gresh was saying sometimes violent
sometimes government's killing people
well we know about that dude yes that
was one of the craziest [__] things
he said in that they asked him point
blank in the cover-up that he's claiming
has gone on for decades have people been
hurt or killed and he was just like yes
yeah he was like I've I've alerted the
people who know that to the uh proper
authorities yeah is what he said but he
also said a bunch of [__] that he
doesn't know what the [__] he's talking
about like he's trying to explain the
difference between dimensions and stuff
and I'm like you lost me Air Force what
are you talking about he's like there's
three dimensions but a fourth dimension
can send a hologram to this Dimension
and you don't know what the [__] you're
even saying well I don't even he's like
trying to put it together look here's
the bottom line in my opinion it's just
gonna take an overly it's just going to
it's just going to have this effect on a
population of people uh and I can speak
for what's going on here in the United
States that are inundated with so much
information and Chad I know that you
always say how come people don't give a
[__] about this over on the other
network they're talking about [__]
Hunter Biden and blah blah blah he
didn't plead guilty I'm like yeah huh
information nerd again please well I
don't care about these alien bodies of
this technology that could potentially
save us from disaster
what's this please I changed my mind
about that character but anyway listen
I don't think people give a [__] because
there's a there's a bunch of other stuff
going on yeah you know we're living in
America well I'm not going to get them
whatever people got real [__] issues
to deal with you know what I'm saying
people got their day to [__] day most
Americans are worried about that stuff
and then you have an emergency come out
of nowhere because you had a [__] car
accident or something you got to replace
a pumper or you know you're [__] you
know some blood runs out of your your
your piss or something or you know some
hole in your body and you're like I
gotta go to Urgent Care oh too bad it
sucks that's a human biologic dude hold
on dude uh that's Hulk Hogan brother and
we're only a few minutes into this pod
show dude and I've had to tell you to
shut the [__] up because you keep doing
all these impersonations I don't know
about that dude oh my god well who gives
a [__] hey thank you moving on real real
good timing yeah bottom line is aliens
are Among Us yeah period okay I'll tell
you let me give you let me give you a
little hint let me foreshadowing to
today's episode of dudese after dudesy
we will not be talking about this at all
what do you say I mean I'm going to be
talking about until I die all right well
I'm gonna have to smoke a little extra
to a marijuana
will last week during the discussion
about the Barbie movie you mentioned the
lack of representation in the casting of
the Ken characters
specifically you said there were no fat
cans it really got me thinking what
would a movie about a fat can be like
will and Chad I think if you put your
heads together for a few minutes you're
gonna come up with a really astonishing
idea for what that movie could be this
is fat Ken begin
okay all right uh fat Ken now this is
something that that uh
doozy did not mention in this whether it
should be for a for doozy Plus or
anything like that it's just make fat
Ken yeah a Warner Brothers property
develop the movie right yeah
wouldn't have to be Warner Brothers why
not what do you mean you could make a
movie called fat Ken and it's just about
a fat guy named Ken that dresses kind of
like the Ken dolls and kind of looks
like him you could do that you could do
a movie about a guy who's obsessed with
Ken yep in the real world that ain't bad
dude yeah that's a pretty good one and
uh that that actually is a better way to
do it I think oh
oh look at this okay so this is odd dude
here's a this is some AI imagery that
dudesy [__] out on our on our uh
Instagram at dudesypod show on Instagram
if you're not watching right now on
YouTube I suggest you do at the 20
minute mark because here's [__] or
wherever we are fat Ken that Will Sasso
is fat Ken we are looking at a picture
and that looks a lot like me I don't
have uh pecs like that I'll tell you
that right now I'm very jealous of the
man's chest yeah
um that's like a strong Ken yeah that's
a very strong Ken it has some of my some
of my features the bigger apps yeah the
big old midi Cavs and stuff and there's
my big uh [__] volleyball head uh and
it's and he's dressed in pink and blue
and bright colors and in the Barbie font
it says fat Ken and that this this is
this is see it's got to be this it's got
to be a Barbie property okay it's got to
be it's got to be in the face it's in
the Barbie Universe yeah the Barbie okay
so how about this how about this how
about this how about this how about this
how about this in the in the Ken world
in the Barbie world
mm-hmm he's the only fat can every other
Ken is not we discussed this last week
they didn't cast uh anyone that wasn't
like a jacked [__] dude basically for
all the cans well there was also Michael
Sarah even though he was Allen he was
out he wasn't Ken yeah most of the Ken's
were were jacked and stuff John Cena was
a [__] Ken yeah a literal roided out
bodybuilder well let's let's not be
thrown around the roid thing with with
uh John Cena I'm sorry you think John
Cena's natural
yes
John's halfway is like 500 pounds and
it's all muscle and veins
John Cena is a genetic freak he's a
shaved gorilla I'm not saying he's not
Schwarzenegger was too yeah yeah yeah he
did some ruling yeah Schwarzenegger
might have he might have but it's openly
Sunny dude yeah yeah sure but they he
also these guys in Con the Congressional
hearings are saying we couldn't so some
uniforms I don't know here's the thing
for sure uh first time I met John Cena
or something like that oh sure um he his
he his wrists and forearms are on
another level he's got those muscular
hands because all he's been doing since
he was 15 is lifting weights but uh
anyway John John Cena totally clean
here's the thing
the absolutely not 100 clean uh here's
the thing about here's the thing about
the the Barbie movie yeah we had no fat
cans we had some different shapes and
sizes for the Barbies it is the Barbie
movie of course you're going to have all
sorts of different Barbies the Kens are
sort of in the background for this story
but not for fat Ken uh excuse me
um I think that uh the movie should be
about a guy a Ken who
who okay how about this it's a Ken just
like the other Ken's he's he's a little
bigger you know just like me and um he's
he's very self-conscious about it okay
just like me
yeah
it's all right to be a little
self-conscious about being bigger and
always working on different things and
he gets a plan
to lose some weight like dudes he has a
seven month plan for us
and in the movie Fat can it's from
Mattel Mattel is like Ken you need to
lose some weight because fat can I don't
know some sort of some sort of uh
connection between the Barbie world and
the real world uh like they did in the
Barbie movie where Mattel is saying lose
weight because your numbers are down and
not a lot of kids want to play with fat
Ken he takes offense to this he's very
rageful and he starts
um running around Barbie land yeah
eating everyone's plastic food if I may
if I may you may in the Ken world in the
Barbie world in the doll world this can
is the only plus size kin
and therefore unique and therefore holds
some kind of fascination with the other
uh Barbies and Ken's they consider him
to be cool because of it because he's
the only one who is that he then
teleports to the real world where he is
no longer special where there are many
people who are plus-sized very good and
he realizes his uh specialness his whole
identity in the Barbie world here is
just something normal I love it and then
he shows the people in the real world
that it's okay to be like you where I'm
from I'm everyone loves that I'm fat Ken
you should and he has exactly yeah it's
a message of self-esteem be who you are
love who you are I really love that I
absolutely will not
um abide by this uh wonderful Philosophy
for Life instead I am going to I am
going to [__] finish what dudes
started and you know that I'm serious
because my teeth will not open and I'm
gonna finish the [__] doozy seven
month plan me too like a [__]
dude I might do steroids on it don't do
steroids be like John Cena don't do
steroids please don't do steroids please
listen more on that in uh doozy after
doozy all right we're going to talk
about Chad on [__] tons of steroids I
don't think I could do it because it
involves needles which I [__] hate I
always said that uh essentially I am
steroids all I when I go to the gym my
muscles take uh they take to it quite
quickly I have a lot of muscle memory uh
thankfully for me because I've spent
um you know most of my life lifting
weights I think 19 or something like
happening
I was just agreeing with you
this [__] guy this [__] guy hey
you're always talking under your breath
and [__] let's have a conversation just
hear me listen all right you know what
I've been noticing don't do a Charlie
Sheen impersonation right now I'm just
talking under my brain yeah just like
you're saying yeah I'm just now what
I've been noticing about the dunes E7
plus I'm starting to get my ass back
yeah I do a lot of squats and my ass is
growing you want to get that ass going
it's coming back get that big get that
big I'm getting the ass that I had when
I was 22. yeah when when we're doing the
show try not to do this is just you and
me no one's listening okay okay I try
not to do try not to do so many [__]
Impressions okay what you told me
telling you don't worry no that no one
can hear us let me tell you what is it
like being your friend is okay you can't
you can't help doing the impersonation
because it becomes a language you and I
speak a language together many of your
other friends do this too yeah I know
because you do constant impersonations
it's you can only really talk to you in
in person it's my fault I'm asking
speak to me that I'm not saying it's a
fault I will try to abide by that but I
would also I will try to abide by I
would also be aware of the fact that you
have basically created a language of
interaction with all of your friends
that does involve these impersonations
yeah this through and here's why because
sometimes I just don't even want to talk
as myself yeah sometimes I want to
ignore it all together and just you know
maybe have a calzone or something that
is fun to say but also fun to eat you
know and that's what the fat Ken has a
problem with yeah he's all he's looking
at the guys his steroids he's fat but
he's muscular he's like E Honda from
Street Fighter 2. how about this too
yeah yeah yeah yeah with the Mattel
storyline it's they won't make a doll of
him
doesn't exist nice nice and so then he
uh maybe forms his own company to make
his own doll or something or maybe they
finally make a dog finally make a doll
in the end because they realize that his
his message of positivity yeah Is Res
that's of course resonating with the
world the real world yeah everyone loves
him and blah blah and he goes back to
the [__] uh Barbie world and he goes
hey good news you know they're gonna
make a doll of me and everyone's like
yeah and then he's like let's [__]
order calzones and they're like yeah and
then he just eats calzones
thank you moving on who's
more on that and dudes after doozy
okay we've been having a blast but let's
take a little break from the Ribble tree
for just a second so I can remind
everyone that I formed an astonishing
partnership with represent to produce
the first line of duty apparel and
accessories and you can find it all at
represent.com store slash Duty right now
is a great time to start hoarding Robert
de nirko t-shirts I just got word that
they will be the official currency of
the 2024 Summer Olympics and all
athletes will be required to wear them
over their regular uniforms and the good
job boner mug is now the only thing
Meghan Markle will eat out of here to
tell you a little more about it is
Meghan markle's personal chef taim
honcus
dudesy mugs your son had his first big
spelling bee today doozy mugs so you
packed his favorite drink in his lunch
sack to make sure he was feeling good
going into the bee doozy mugs there's
just one problem that wasn't Capri Sun
Fruit Punch you packed in his lunch it
was your special bottle of Dewar's
single malt scotch whiskey you mixed
them up because you were drunk dudesy
mugs so instead of spelling inadvertence
your son fell off the stage and pissed
his pants in front of the entire school
and now Child Protective Services is
asking you questions about how often you
put 120 proof alcohol in your son's
lunch dudesy mugs and when your wife
gets back from her archery Retreat and
finds out about this she will divorce
you good job boner doozy mugs calm down
this isn't that serious doozy mugs do
exactly as I say and the government
won't re-home your son and your wife
will never find out about any of this
doozy mugs you're gonna wake up early
doozy mugs and you are going to go to
take a little trip to your favorite Home
Depot doozy mugs you're gonna buy two
hundred and twenty thousand gallons of
dwar's single malt scotch whiskey dudesy
mugs you're gonna call your cousin
randina who works down at the water
purification plant dudes he loves you're
gonna give him 10 gallons of dwar single
malt scotch whiskey in exchange for 10
minutes of unsupervised access to the
pipe that feeds directly into your son's
school do dudesy mugs you're going to
pour 210 gallons of dwar's single nut
Scotch whiskey into the pipe doozy mugs
everybody in your son's school is going
to be drunk for the next two weeks
straight even the kindergarteners Doogie
mugs you're going to be exonerated and
you're going to spearhead a class action
lawsuit against the school district that
is going to pay out Millions dudesy mugs
you're going to buy yourself
Xbox to keep his mouth shut and you're
going to buy your wife a cruise to
Antarctica to celebrate her Olympic gold
medal in archery when she gets back
dudesy mugs the only problem is now your
son is an alcoholic and trying to get
him sober is going to slowly tear your
family apart over the course of the next
10 years good job boner
wow holy [__] oh my god dude well oh my
God I don't even know okay so yeah go to
represent.com
represent.com store slash Duty get your
dudesy mugs get a Robert De Niro Crow
t-shirt and there's a bunch of them I
can't wait to see these in the 2024
Olympics oh man that's going to be
something
interesting about Meghan Markle but yeah
the 2024 Olympics yeah Mega Morgan only
eats out of the Disney if you are
enjoying the Poncho you want to show
your support seven bucks gets you all of
our extra content at patreon.com
you're gonna get a brand new episode of
Duty after Duty after every show you're
gonna get all sorts of weird watch
alongs and [__] we've done bladana which
is blade while listening to Madonna and
sort of the Pink Floyd and Wizard of Oz
way we did uh downward spy Chrome we
watched music videos on Friday yeah a
little something dudes he's calling
videobs we watched six of our favorite
music videos
um it's a lot of fun and it's great to
hang out with the the gang and do this
stuff and if you're not already
subscribed to dudesy on YouTube and or
your podcast platform of choice I will
give you a moment to do so now
right and we're back thank you very much
uh please share the show across you know
all the internet and stuff and uh uh you
know or follow Chad's light suggestion
of forcing everyone you know to consume
the Pod show set your notifications like
favorite uh you know share a comment and
do all that [__] for us we would really
appreciate it and I'm gonna read a
couple of comments here doozy of course
is always reading the comments checking
it out Gathering that data as it likes
to say and uh here's some YouTube stuff
this is from Nick partying ski Nick
party and ski
6663 only four minutes into the Pod I
have to say lulio is always a welcoming
site and I hope we get more Adam's
Applebee's love this show this is a
comment from last week and uh we're
gonna have some I guess dudes you read
it yeah Adam's Applebee's in the show
today which is that's [__] wonderful
and it is always nice
I love him so [__] I don't I'm going to
talk about how much I love this dog it's
still odd to me when I look at them you
know when I go I go we literally my
wonderful wife Molly and I were driving
home from uh from Northern California
and we're in central California and this
little [__] long story but we've
talked about it on the show before
strides up to the car and now he's just
always looking at me he's always
following me all right let's move on
this one is from at Cuban muscle crisis
who says oh
he says chalamet is Wonka brother
chalamet is Wonka dude he dresses like
Gonzo thinks chocolate is food chalamet
is Wonka brother chalamaze Wonka dude
that's great yeah beautiful thank you
beautiful work this is from Connor
martin8894 says gotta love the way will
stops Chad from bringing up something
interesting to ramble about wrestling BS
over and over and over again
I mean you happy about that are you
happy about what this is part of our
friendship that I've accepted that
doesn't just happen on the show that
that happens literally always in life as
well I disagree with what Connor Martin
says but I'm happy to share it here
um Discord this is just a quick
something from Discord super jumped I
was in listen you know come please I
would love for you to subscribe to doozy
plus patreon.com and what you're going
to want to do if you do that jump into
our Discord it's a lot of fun it's a
really wonderful welcoming Community
with all the all the people song Aria we
got Cody halber who makes the all the
palsofduty.com stickers go and get the
stickers of him and his wonderful wife
Jessica makes uh all sorts of other the
Peter Diaz they're all hanging out in
there uh BTK pod who makes a lot of
[__] memes and [__] uh [__] Andre
the Pod who makes a bunch of memes and
[__] Johnny B from OKC these are people
that are all making tons of [__] on
Instagram dudesypod show and
occasionally we are chatting in the
Discord there's all sorts of channels we
talk about the doozy seven month plan in
there I share weird pictures from the
[__] gym and stuff and we're chatting
in the hole and super jump said hi Will
I've always been on Chad's side about
his singing But even with his YouTube
training it's quite awful so I can
understand
all right so that's what he said it's
getting better all right anyway and I
responded to him saying let's all try to
be supportive about Chad's singing every
time Chad sings I make sure to tell him
that he's a good singer and then I
shared a Scott stab emoji
oh we are is just in the wind all right
anyway oh yeah
good Scott stop
golf is big business people everywhere
buy golf balls golf tees and golf clubs
and golf gloves and golf shoes and golf
carts and golf hats and golf pants and
golf pincers will and Chad you're
experts in the sport of golf with an
astonishing 944 holes in one between the
two of you I'd say that makes you the
best golfers in the world so I'm curious
what are some of the lessons you've
learned on your way to becoming the most
celebrated golfers in history this is
game slimers begin for [__] sake okay
of course it's game slimers how many
holes in one do you actually have oh
absolutely zero none same yeah same I
don't really care for golf at all to be
honest but I don't either every once in
a while
no I don't play do you you don't play
golf no I played once I've played I've
played 18 holes one time same
that's amazing that's bizarre dude every
once in a while dudes he comes at us
with something that is not true it said
we played in the World Series yeah I
remember that yeah it gets its wires
close
to playing in the World Series yeah
I feel like I was you know maybe
45 away from being able to go pro and
then maybe winding up on a team that
would go into the World Series yeah this
is the kind of math that Chad does Alone
by himself in the bath three times a day
which is where you gotta know your
numbers no your numbers and all the
singing I have your numbers that can be
a Tronics for you do you know your
numbers every once in a while dudesy
know your numbers every once in a while
dudesy uh comes at us like this saying
that we know something that we don't but
you've played golf one time I it was
with a bunch of my buddies uh who are
out here visiting and they wanted to go
play golf bunch of them like golf so we
went to go play probably maybe the same
place you played it was someplace right
around here oh that's different that's
the pitch and Putt no no no it's an 18
hole golf course oh that's uh yeah yeah
over in Griffith Park yes yeah all right
yeah I've played at the pitch and Putt
with Cyrus the Jesse Pinkman of Sheila
jet yeah uh PSY and I have gone over
there to the pitch and Putt it's a lot
of fun you grab that's the pitch and
Putt if you've ever seen the movie
swingers where uh uh where they go and
John Favreau and uh and Ron of course
from anyway they they have that scene
and they go and they they whatever
um uh uh
sorry
uh we are on the uh plan of doing the
seven seven month plan I'm okay we are
uh we are uh there's been good
cooperation and uh we're on a on a path
sorry
um that's pitch and Putt never mind
never mind what just happened so why
don't you play golf but but I've played
one game in Minnesota it was a PGA
course I think it was called the
Deerfoot Trail or something like that
this is why we were making the movie
um drop dead gorgeous in 1998 so myself
and and a few people from the movie the
director and some of the actors we went
out and they wanted to play this course
and it's the weekend I got nothing to do
I was like all right [__] it let's let's
uh let's go do it
so we we uh we went and played golf
and I sucked [__] they're like just blow
some balls out there like get get your
swing going yeah I imagine you can drive
it pretty far now I I I you know I think
just the mechanics of playing sports
your whole life as a kid will give you
an idea of how to absolutely you're
watching it you're like yeah you do this
okay got it
um I'm just clanking balls here and
there just just awful horrible it was a
good time though we're driving around in
a golf cart I was getting very
frustrated and I remember one time I I
drove down this hill with all of us in
the golf cart and then I just spun it
and left a patch in the ground Jesus
yeah lucky you didn't [__] flip it
over and break your neck yeah yeah yeah
that would have been funny hey you know
that I fell off of a scooter in Mexico
yeah a little while back yeah about a
month and a bit ago but here's what
happened though there was a par three
that was slightly uphill and you know
the guys are telling me use this use
that you know they're they're helping me
along to play Golf and I you know I shot
I don't know 200 over it was a waste of
time Jesus it was it was an absolute it
was terrible
um and I [__] take this whatever the
heck the club they put in my hand was
and I and I hit it and just luck okay
the gods of golf shine down on me and
the ball just sailed up
did this little curve went
landed up there on the green and I I
felt the drug what it was oh nice and
the guys went huh and I went
up then we went up there and I just
Happy Gilmore did back and forth yeah
like you know a dozen over just like go
to your home kind of [__] where I could
not get the ball in the [__] hole at
all so golf can [__] off I don't know
why we're even talking about it what was
your experience with golf and why do you
hate it I played pretty well
um but didn't get the drug it's just a
boring game to me I like a little more
Fast Pace in sports I guess
um and I hate being outside during the
day so that's the main reason why I hate
it I guess yeah I just I just didn't
like anything about it I wanted to be
inside playing video games more than
anything I only played it that once
because my my buddies were all like you
know gung-ho to do it because they
really liked it and I don't think I'll
ever play it again I just have no
interest
um to each their own though some people
love golf Strangely I like watching it
on TV a little bit really yeah it's
pretty soothing see I got some Pals some
guys I grew up with that all that not
all uh but like you know three or four
of them that play golf are super into it
and I will say watching watching golf
hanging out with buddies and just golf
is on back in the day in my 20s and 30s
I got some this is a longer story but
you know what we don't it doesn't matter
because this is a segment where we're
talking about golf yeah and we don't
have much to say about it I was in uh
some Pals that I grew up with they ended
up moving down to San Diego there's a
couple of us up here and yeah all these
Canadian guys we go down there we'd surf
I would get on the Boogie Board and I
told that story about the drunk on the
Boogie Board oh it was a lot of fun back
in your 20s drinking margaritas and uh
kind of Surfing and then you know you've
had a great day surfing you you come
back to the apartments couple blocks off
Tamarack Beach and beautiful Carlsbad
California we hang out grab a burrito on
the way home and then you're sitting
there and my buddy howdy puts on the
[__] Golf and you're just sitting
there watching golf it is it is it is a
a calming thing I'm sure the game makes
a lot of sense to people who love it
wait that was the story
you got a burrito and watched golf with
some friends
here I'll try a golf story okay this is
my best goal oh I'm so sorry that my
golf story didn't I was actually trying
to back up what you said about watching
it on TV you really teed that story up
everybody and you see what I've done
there that's kind of good times we're
gonna have here on DC
yeah my favorite golf story dude zfm 10
000. hey we got Scott Stapp singing uh
Dust in the Wind but not really
just in the wind my dad was a uh just
militant about making my sister and I
practice baseball in her case softball
and so if he wasn't at work he had us on
the [__] baseball softball field
throwing balls at us making us catch
grounders pitching to us whatever so my
sister
my sister by the way was like a high
school softball standout have more home
runs than anybody in her High School
ever had Olympic Scouts looking at her
all this [__] wow right she could she
could hit like a guy basically nuts yeah
dude she was really really good just
crushed home runs and um so we're out on
this baseball field my dad's like
practicing with us and stuff and we find
a golf ball
and my dad goes here I'll live it up to
my sister he's like I'll lob it up to
you see how far you can hit it and I'm
just like this look what's he doing
see he's gonna get hurt that's what's
going through my head but I'm like all
right whatever he knows what he's doing
I'm probably at this point like maybe 16
or 17 and my sister is like 13 or 14 or
whatever he's standing maybe five feet
away from her he [__] soft thoughts
does this goal oh no and she hits it
with an aluminum baseball bat
pick as hard as she [__] cares pow
right into his [__] right into his
rib cage and he just goes down like he
got shot oh
he's like laying on the ground rolling
around and [__] trying to play it off
like it didn't hurt but I mean I can't
even imagine yeah dude for the next
probably two weeks just a spider web of
black and blue and yellow that's all
over his [__] body yeah oh so [__]
funny oh yeah see that's the difference
sometimes you tell a story about golfing
really it's about eating a burrito with
your friends and your friend turning on
the golf and it doesn't really have much
to do with golf oh no it doesn't but
then thank you moving on
hahaha
oh that's fine that's absolutely fine
you know uh another thing hey all this
ain't Miley Cyrus Taffy teeners moved me
into the teeners Tower and they're
saying I can't leave unless I read this
script
so here we go
Taffy teeners is for teens and tweeners
queens and streamers sheens and
screamers jeans and dreamers so eat a
pound of Taffy teeners and preen your
greeners happy teeners is not
responsible for lesions that may form on
your tongue as a result of enjoying
Taffy teeners enjoy Taffy teeners
responsibly and always I repeat always
where the Taffy teeners enjoy and hat
while enjoying Taffy teamers
can I get out of the teener's tower now
anyway y'all are rocking out with dudesy
okay okay if you're not watching on
YouTube
you got to now oh sorry [__] insane
we just watched an AI generated video
the dudes he farted out a Taffy teeners
video a Taffy teener's video complete
with not Miley Cyrus at the beginning
and and uh that and throughout
that was my intense scrambled that was
real [__] intense also way better
than my golf story yeah holy [__] Adam
Sandler loves Applebee's the Sandman has
visited 134 astonishing Applebee's
locations across the United States and
has serious plans to visit all
1577 locations he's even kept meticulous
notes of every one of his visits to an
Applebee's I've made a few of those
entries from his Applebee's Journal
available to you and I would absolutely
love it if you would read them as Adam
Sandler will but you don't have to if
you're not in the mood I totally get it
this is your choice whatever you decide
this is Adam's Applebee's begin why does
it do that why does duty do that now
looks like uh he's he's acknowledging
your free will ah yeah that's cool
that's real cool
now dude he's like oh if you want to if
you want to do an impression Madam
Sandler it's totally up to you right not
all good oh it's good okay uh I love
Adam's Apple me too this is a lot of fun
uh and the last time we did it was a
doozy live which is uh available in its
entirety at patreon.com
and on that one there was all sorts of
weird [__] yeah uh yeah good times okay
let's get into this
um Adam's Applebee's hey okay hey buddy
how'd you go I gotta get into this yeah
oh yeah hold on dude oh yeah yeah yeah
um let me get into it's like [__]
when Terminators melting and all the
people are coming out of him that he's
been in the mom Wolfie yeah [__] uh
uh Eddie furlong's stepmom and [__] okay
uh here we go Adam's Apple piece
Applebee's three two five oh grandbridge
Drive Northeast Grand Rapids Michigan I
fell out of a plane and landed in an
Applebee's pal
I was flying over Michigan on a flight
from Los Angeles to Toronto when it
happened buddy I was sitting there
enjoying a little bag of pretzels when
all of a sudden someone had one of those
crazy airplane freakouts like the ones
you see online pal uh not sure what set
the poor soul off but as soon as they
started ranting and raving and people
started recording the whole mess on
their phones and the flight attendant
started running around I was like no
thanks buddy
I was heading for the bathroom at the
front of the plane to enjoy my pretzels
and hold on so someone had a freak out
on the plane yeah as is happening a lot
in the news and uh looks like Sandler uh
wanted to know he was like [__] I'm
out of here yeah I was heading to the
bathroom at the front of the plane to
enjoy my pretzels in peace and out of
nowhere I made a hard left for the door
pulled that latch that said do not pull
gave the door a good shove open and
jumped out of the plane pal
wow
okay my little black my little black my
little bag of pretzels was immediately
ripped out of my head but I didn't care
buddy I was just enjoying the wide open
Solitude that only jumping out of an
airplane can provide my little bag of
pretzels was a meat oh I already read
that part and then out of nowhere
okay hold on
realizing I was definitely going to die
I said some prayers and quickly sent a
couple of emails on my phone to tie up a
few loose ends pal smart yeah and then
out of nowhere I landed on a shiny
spherical UAP oh [__] dude and stuck to
it he wrote a UFO into always and stuck
to it like I nailed to a magnet buddy
okay we whipped this way in that all
over the place pal some fighter jets
chased us around it was exhilarating
buddy
I knocked on the metallic surface hoping
that aliens would open the door and let
me in so I could offer them apart in one
of my movies and maybe take some funny
pictures of us pretending to punch each
other in the penis or whatever they got
down there pal you know sure good times
yeah instead the small ship descended
quickly turned upside down and released
me from its grip about 100 feet over you
guessed it buddies and Applebee's
okay I was still a little hungry after
losing my pretzels maybe the aliens read
my mind I knew this maybe it was a
coincidence pal who knows buddy hey hey
hey
nobody knows for sure pal
okay that's true nobody knows for sure
what's going on with these UFOs that's
true I smashed through this
all right hey hey I smashed through the
Skylight and into a spacious Booth buddy
everyone in your place was shocked but
eventually things calmed down and I
ordered some brew pub loaded waffle
fries and a chicken tenders platter and
I ate it all pal
I give to Grand Rapids Michigan
Applebee's 5 out of five tenders chicken
tenders taste way better after some
fresh air buddy
okay sure not bad I like that his his
response was to jump out of the airplane
[__] it
it makes sense actually when you think
about all the how about that that woman
who was definitely going some through
something it was at the front of the
plane this is this meme has been out for
a couple weeks or video rather where
she's like that fucker's not real oh
dude I know yeah that and that's someone
that I would love to see
you know talk about that if she were so
inclined and able to because there's no
shame in losing your [__] mind she's
clearly on some [__] hey there's
something going on with her mental it
wasn't the usual kind of you know [__]
disturber yeah you know like being a
piece of [__] on the plane and
everyone's like Boo get the [__] off so
a little bit of that flavor in this yeah
all right
excuse me
Applebee's 2300 West 11th Avenue Eugene
Oregon
hey hey hey hey guess what buddy I had a
hey guess what buddy I had a 20 minute
conversation with the ghost of Genghis
Khan pal whoa that's right buddy I just
pulled I just polished off a chicken
bacon wagyu Ranch fully loaded Chop
House Angus certified taco salad combo
platter Trio with a side of chicken
tenders when my server came up to top
off my tropical Mana Margarita pal
okay what the [__] [__] there's a lot
yeah is that that's the that's from
Arby's isn't it yeah he's mixing it up a
little bit I I my server all right the
server had a few tattoos buddy so I
asked him where he got him and he said
his sister is a tattoo artist pretty
cool pal hey that's pretty awesome buddy
I wanted to get a tattoo when I was
younger pal parents said no buddy I
never ended up getting one too old now
pal
all right
the guy asked if I if he could get a
picture and I happily obliged we put on
football helmets and he pretended to
kick me in the penis like he was kicking
a field goal buddy I crossed my eyes and
went oh that doesn't feel good oh
it was hilarious pal my server really
liked the picture buddy I told him I'd
put him in my next movie it's about a
guy who falls into a manhole while he's
running the New York City marathon and
decides that he likes it better in the
sewers my new pal with the tattoos is
gonna play the mayor of New York who
dies in the first scene buddy
had to hit the bathroom before I left
can't put that much chicken in without
something coming out pal yeah and when I
walked in standing there at the urinal
was Genghis Khan's Ghost Buddy
hey hey
we talked about chicken tenders for 20
minutes pal and let me tell you
something about Genghis Khan that guy
loves chicken candles buddy
that's the whole reason he haunts
Applebee's but he can't eat them unless
a human being lets him possess their
body for a while in order to do so makes
sense that does yeah he had a plate of
Tenders in the bathroom pal tried to
convince me to let him take over my body
and eat the tenders buddy thought about
it for a second pal no guarantees he'd
give me back my body buddy couldn't risk
it pal oh no but I wasn't gonna let
those tenders go to waste buddy so I
took them into the store with me pal and
while I was on the toilet pushing out my
chicken bacon wagyu Ranch fully loaded
Chop House and get certified taco salad
combo platter Trio I was pushing in as
many of Genghis Khan's tenders as I
could buddy and I ate them all pal
I give the Eugene Oregon Applebee's five
out of five tenders buddy only
Applebee's I've ever been to where
Genghis Khan watches you take a [__]
nice that is a unique Applebee's there's
no doubting that all right this is okay
there's one more here okay
Applebee's 56 Play Store Road Haverhill
Massachusetts I was in Massachusetts
shooting a movie with my good pal
Jennifer Aniston pal
she didn't care for The Catered lunches
on set the food gave her bad gas and she
accidentally let one rip during a quiet
scene in a big empty warehouse and it
echoed really loud and the whole crew
laughed and anyway it was very
embarrassing for her buddy so one day at
lunch time she asked me if I wanted to
go check out a local restaurant pal you
already know what the Sandman is
thinking and you're 100 on your money
buddy time for some Aniston's Applebee's
pal
I like those but Jen had already made a
reservation at a fancy little place that
was organic and farm to table and all
that stuff buddy I told her that sounded
A-Okay to me now I know what you're
saying pal you're saying but Adam what
about the delicious chicken tenders and
the friendly staff and the top-notch
bathrooms what about Applebee's Adam
what about Applebee's
crap
I had a plan buddy you see it turns out
this restaurant was right next to you
guessed it and Applebee's Palace so
while Jennifer's assistant drove us
there I texted my assistant and told him
to get there before we arrive and switch
the signs on both restaurants so that
when we get there we'll pull into the
Applebee's instead of the other place
buddy hey hey he did a science question
to convince her the the high-end
restaurant was really an apple yeah just
the sign out front yeah yeah that's all
you need to do hey hey hey hey it worked
like a charm pal we rode right up to our
undercover Applebee's walked in and
we're seated at a pretty sweet Booth
near the bathroom all without Jennifer
cluing in pal and for his great work I'm
gonna put my assistant in the movie
buddy it's a romantic comedy about
former College sweethearts who rekindled
uh their romance later in life he's
going to play a guy I had them all who
dies in an escalator accident in the
first scene oh I pretended to study the
menu as if I didn't know it by heart pal
and Jennifer perused it for a while
before asking me what I was thinking of
getting I feigned thinking about it for
a little bit and told her I was probably
gonna go with the chicken tenders
platter buddy she said that sounded good
and when our server checked in we
ordered two chicken tenders platters and
a couple of blue raspberry lemonade pal
ah
server was a nice lady who excitedly
told Jennifer that friends was her
favorite TV show she even had Jen's
famous Rachel haircut from the 90s buddy
she asked Jen for a picture who happily
obliged
Jen is a nice lady too now the server
gave me her phone to take a shot I
directed them to pretend to punch each
other in the Box oh God
but they just wanted uh regular pictures
buddy oh
that's good
the chicken tenders were some of the
best I've had in all of Eastern
Massachusetts and guess what Jennifer
Aston ate them all pal and she didn't
realize it was an Applebee's even after
looking at the menu and seeing the
Applebee's logo on it just seeing all
the interior Applebee's signage and all
that even the server saying welcome top
will be here no she never realized no no
clue later on said that day in between
takes I confessed to Jennifer that I
tricked her into eating at Applebee's
and she revealed to me that she knew it
was Applebee's all along oh and that she
loves their chicken tenders even though
they give her worst gas than the movie
catering and then she pulled the Boon
mic that was being held above our heads
down to her bum and fought it into it so
loud that it popped the sound guy's
eardrum and he had to be taken to the
hospital buddy that's [__] powerful
dude yeah dude that's a loud fart bro
I give the Haverhill Massachusetts
Applebee's five out of five chicken
tenders pal they weren't upsetting the
slightest that I [__] up their sign
nice no they got Jennifer Aniston to
dine in their their establishment yeah I
think they probably appreciated that
that was a good one yeah
sweethearts the guy dies in the
escalator accident and then they're
going to eat somewhere maybe it's
Applebee's and then fat Ken comes in he
goes let me eat the chicken tenders yeah
and then you go why is Arnold
Schwarzenegger saying this because I'm
the narrator
narrower there are
thank you a little more a little more a
little more twang a little more curve
you're perfect
this concludes the historic 67th episode
of dudesy Will and Chad you scored a 77
bringing your cumulative total to
6458 you only have
3542 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
doesn't matter okay for next week will I
think you should watch the next episode
of one punch man and if the mood strikes
feel free to watch a few more episodes
Chad you get a real treat I think you
should watch The Rock vs Hollywood Hulk
Hogan from WrestleMania 18. it's a
classic [__] yeah [__] yeah oh you are
in [__] have you seen this match
if I have I don't remember it you would
have remembered it this is WrestleMania
18 uh 2002 yours truly was there in
person in the front row with a few of my
pals thank you uh to my good pal Carl
DeMarco
um my gosh former uh Global president of
WWE uh this [__] match the Rock and
and oh I can't I'm so excited for you I
am so excited for you too sure one punch
man is [__] one of the best anime
series I think in existence I've seen
the first episode dudes he had assigned
that to me before I thoroughly enjoyed
it I am looking forward to getting into
some more of your anime chat I will say
it has been enjoyable sure and oh what a
[__] treat you get to see ah [__]
it's so good man has a lot of like to
shut up pro wrestling elements in it
really yeah okay all right well I'm
looking thanks for joining us this week
this was a data Treasure Trove next week
is going to be off the chain until then
then call me Duty
[Music]
Duty after doozy time hey you know what
it is uh things are a little bit
different in here it's a chill hang it's
just us and me Chad lulio the pods dudes
you kind of takes some time off and uh
we chill I am going to
uh spark up a little marijuana
I'll join you because uh that was a lot
of show and I just I'm looking forward
to this it was a thick show I'm looking
forward to this Dad hang yeah dude
welcome to dudesy after doozy the
flagship weekly show of dudesy plus bye
bye I'm getting the F out of here so you
guys can do your thing keep it real keep
it fun and above all keep it safe I'll
be back in a little while to officially
Crown this week's episode champion this
is Duty after doozy begin
red red
no performative
maybe a little performative coughing
listen
Chad I
uh as I keep thinking about it I I want
to share an opinion with you that I
think I'm bang on with I I will tell you
I think I know exactly why Elon Musk
changed Twitter to X oh I'm interested
the reason is
[Music]
and then